>> Tucker: THERE INTALINGS
UNDERWAY IN WASHINGTON OVER
MEMOS.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ASKED
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO RELEASE
THEIR MEMO.
IT’S A REBUTTAL TO THE NUNES
MEMO OF 10 DAYS AGO IN THE
FBI.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE WILL
RELEASE IT BUT AT THIS POINT
THE MEMO CONTAINS TOO MUCH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION THAT
HE MUST BE TAKEN OUT OR
ALTERED BEFORE THE PUBLIC
CAN SEE IT SOME WERE SAYING
THAT WAS THE PLAN ALL ALONG
THAT DEMOCRATS DELIBERATELY
CREATED A MEMO THEY KNEW
COULDN’T BE RELEASED.
CONGRESSMAN ERIC SWALWELL
REPRESENTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> TUCKER I GREAT TO BE BACK
AFTER OUR COURT ORDERED
COOLING OFF PERIOD.
>> EXACTLY WHICH I WAS
THINKING OFF TODAY AND
GRATEFUL THAT YOU CAME BACK.
SO 10 DAYS AGO FEBRUARY 2ND
WAS THE DAY THE NUNES MEMO
WAS RELEASED AND THIS SHOW
HAD CALLED FOR IT TO BE
RELEASED.
BECAUSE OF THAT YOU SAID WE
WERE WORK FOR VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
MEMO, THE MINORITY MEMO, AND
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
RELEASED AND WE CALLED FOR
IT TO BE RELEASED ON THE
SHOW AS WELL.
DO YOU STILL THINK I’M
WORKING FOR PUTIN NOW THAT I
WANT YOUR MEMO RELEASED.
>> I NEVER SAID THAT I SAID
YOU ARE MAKING THE ARGUMENT
AND SAME SIDE OF THEM.
>> Tucker: I WAS ACTUALLY
DOING HIS BIDDING.
SO THE QUESTION IS ASKING
FOR YOUR MEMO TO BE RELEASED
DOING HIS BIDDING, ALSO?
>> YEAH.
NO, I SAID WHEN YOU ARE ON
THE SAME SIDE YOU HAVE TO
ASK WHOSE BIDDING ARE YOU
DOING?
>> Tucker: SO NOW, HOLD ON,
WAIT, PLEASE ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
I’M ASKING FOR YOUR -- YOU
SAID THAT BECAUSE I WANTED
NUNES’ MEMO TO BECOME
PUBLIC.
NOW I WOULD LIKE ADAM SCHIFF
AND YOUR MEMO TO BECOME
PUBLIC.
AM I STILL ON PUTIN’S SIDE?
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS IS
GOING TO BE A SHORT
INTERVIEW BECAUSE YOU AND I
AGREE THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO
SHOULD BE PUBLIC.
>> Tucker: SO THE ANSWER IS
IF I WANT THE REPUBLICAN
MEMO TO BE RELEASED I’M ON
PUTIN’S SIDE BUT WHEN I WANT
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO TO BE TO
BE RELEASED I’M ON GOD’S
SIDE?
>> I THINK BOTH OF US SHOULD
AGREE WE SHOULD GET PAST THE
MEMO ATTACKS ON PROCESS AND
GET TO THE EVIDENCE IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: WHAT’S SO
STRIKING THOUGH IS THAT WHEN
NUNES MEMO IT’S HURTING
NATIONAL SECURITY AND
SUBVERTING THE RULER RULE OF
LAW.
APPARENTLY THIS MEMO YOU ARE
RELEASING HAS CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION IT IN IT
APPARENTLY IT DOES THE WHY
IS IT NOT SUBVERTING THE
RULE OF LAW.
>> WE DID SOMETHING THE
REPUBLICANS WEREN’T WILLING
TO DO.
HE WOULD ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
REVIEW IT IF THERE IS
ANYTHING IN THERE THAT WOULD
HURT THE RULE OF LAW OR
NATIONAL SECURITY WE WOULD
WANT THAT REDACTED.
IT SEEMS ODD THAT THE
PRESIDENT NOW WANTS TO
LISTEN TO THE FBI WHEN HE
WAS WILLING TO RELEE LEASE
THE MEMO BEFORE EVEN HEARING
FROM THEM OR LOOKING AT THE
MEMO.
>> Tucker: GREAT RESPECTER
OF THE FBI AND THAT’S THE
CASE HAVE YOU MADE FOR
MONTHS THAT ANYONE WHO
QUESTIONS THE FBI IS
UNPATRIOTIC AND THEY PROTECT
YOUR LIFE EVEN AS YOU SLEEP
AND HOW DARE YOU QUESTION
THEIR JUDGMENT.
ARE YOU QUESTIONING THEIR
JUDGMENT?
WOULDN’T YOU WANT THE FBI TO
HOLD THAT MEMO IF THEY
BELIEVE IT IMPAYROLLS
NATIONAL SECURITY?
WE DO AND WORKING WITH THEM
RIGHT NOW.
THE WAY THE PRESIDENT IS
WORKING WITH SUSPICIOUS.
WE WANT TO KNOW IF HE IS
PRESSURING THEM TO HOLD
BACK.
>> Tucker: I ARE SAYING THE
FBI IS SUBJECT TO POLITICAL
PRESSURES?
I THOUGHT YOU SAID IT WAS
ABOVE POLITICS?
ISN’T THAT THE POINT YOU
MADE NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
>> HE HAS ALREADY FIRED THE
GUY WHO WAS INVESTIGATING
HIM.
TUCK TONGUE ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE FBI IS A POLITICAL TOOL.
I THOUGHT I WAS IMMORAL FOR
SUGGESTING THAT 10 DAYS AGO
BUT NOW YOU ARE SUGGESTING
IT.
>> THEY ARE NOT A POLITICAL
TOOL.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT YOU
JUST SAID THAT.
THEY HAD JUST BEEN
DIDN’T YOU JUST SAY THEY HAD
BEEN PRESSURED.
>> I WANT TO KNOW IF HE IS
PRESSURING THEM.
HE CAN APPLY PRESSURE
WITHOUT THEM BEING
PRESSURED.
WE SHOULD WORK WITH THEM.
BUT, AGAIN, TUCKER.
THIS IS ALL A DISTRACTION.
IT’S A CHARADE ACTUALLY.
WE REALLY SHOULD BE HEARING
FROM WITNESSES BECAUSE IT
MAY.
>> Tucker: I SURPRISE YOU.
>> WE HAVEN’T HEARD FROM A
WITNESS IN OUR INVESTIGATION
IN OVER A MONTH NOW.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
LOOK, AGAIN, JUST TO BE
TOTALLY CLEAR.
I THINK THAT CLASSIFICATION
IS USED TO SHORE UP PEOPLE’S
POWER IN WASHINGTON.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE WE
CAN’T BECAUSE THEY ARE
CLASSIFIED FOR NO GOOD
REASON.
SO I’M VERY SYMPATHETIC TO
YOUR CASE.
WHAT I’M NOT SYMPATHETIC TOO
IS THE CHANGING GOAL LINE
HERE.
WHEN YOU DO SOMETHING IT’S
GREAT.
IT’S IN THE NATIONAL
INTEREST.  WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS DO THE EXACT
SAME THING, IT’S SOMEHOW
DOING THE BIDDING OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
DO YOU SEE WHAT I’M SAYING?
>> WELL, NO, TUCKER, WHAT I
SEE IS THE FBI SAID IT WOULD
BE EXTRAORDINARILY RECKLESS
TO RELEASE A MEMO AND THE
PRESIDENT WENT AHEAD AND DID
IT ANYWAY.
NOW THEY SAID THEY HAVE
CONCERN ABOUT OURS.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE’RE WORKING WITH THEM.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO THE
HOUSE FLOOR AND JUST READING
IT RECKLESSLY.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM
BECAUSE WE STILL BELIEVE IN
THE RULE OF LAW AND THE
INSTITUTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: CAN I ASK YOU A
QUESTION THOUGH?
WHY DID YOU SEND IT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE?
WHY DIDN’T YOU ASK THE FBI
FIRST?
I MEAN, YOU ARE PART OF THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE COMMITTEE.
YOU COULD HAVE ASKED THEM
PRIVATELY HEY, IS THERE
ANYTHING IN HERE YOU THINK
WOULD IMPERIL AMERICAN
NATIONAL SECURITY BEFORE YOU
SENT IT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
BECAUSE YOU DIDN’T BECAUSE
YOU WANTED TO GRANDSTAND
ABOUT IT OBVIOUSLY.
RIGHT?
>> NO.
IT’S NOT GRANDSTANDING.
IT’S ABOUT AN ATTACK THAT
OCCURRED ON OUR COUNTRY.
WITNESSES IN THIS
INVESTIGATION NOW BEING
GIVEN INFORMATION BY THE
REPUBLICANS AND US WANTING
TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
GOD FORBID WE HAVE A ROUGHLY
LAW AND A PROCESS THAT’S
WORKED FOR OVER 200.
>> Tucker: WHY DIDN’T YOU
ASKED THE FBI AHEAD OF TIME.
RUN THE MEMO BY THE FBI
BEFORE YOU SENT IT OVER TO
THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> TUCKER, WE HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING THE RULES THAT
WERE GIVEN.
WE ARE IN THE MINORITY RIGHT
NOW.
>> Tucker: NO ANSWER?
OKAY.
>> HOW IT WOULD BE RUN IF WE
WERE IN THE MAJORITY.
>> Tucker: I KNOW WE WOULD
BE IN THE MIDDLE OF
IMPEACHMENT.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS OVER A YEAR.
YOU SUGGEST YOU HAD THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE PEOPLE
AROUND HIM BASICALLY SOLD
OUT OUR COUNTRY TO A HOSTILE
FOREIGN POWER RUSSIA.
YOU PRESENT NOD EVIDENCE OF
THAT YOU SAID IT’S EITHER
CLASSIFIED OR THE
INVESTIGATION IS ONGOING.
I WANT TO MAKE A DEAL LIVE
ON TV.
IF YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE
THAT TRUMP OR ANYONE AROUND
HIM COLLUDED WITH PUTIN TO
WIN THE ELECTION, I WILL
GIVE YOU A HALF AN HOUR OF
THIS SHOW LIVE ON FOX, BIG
AUDIENCE AND CAN YOU PRESENT
IT I WILL LET YOU PRESENT
THE EVIDENCE.
I MEAN THAT BECAUSE THIS HAS
GONE ON TOO LONG AND I WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THE EVIDENCE IS
FINALLY.
FAIR?
>> YEAH.
FAIR, TUCKER.
BUT WE’RE NOT EVEN LOOKING
FOR COLLUSION.
THAT’S THE PROBABLE ON OUR
COMMITTEE.
WE ARE ATTACKING THE
PROCESS.
WE NORTH INTERVIEWING
WITNESSES.
IF YOU GAVE US TIME TO
INTERVIEW WITNESSES AND THE
SUBPOENA POWER, I PROMISE
YOU WE COULD TELL THE
COUNTRY ONCE AND FOR ALL
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: IT’S GONE ON FOR
OVER A YEAR.
IF YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE AT
ALL OF COLLUSION, ANY.
I DON’T CARE HOW SMALL IT
IS.
I WILL GIVE THE FLOOR TO YOU
AND I WILL MEAN THAT.
I WANT TO WRAP THIS UP.
I’M SURE DO YOU, TOO.
YOU ARE NOT ENJOYING IT?
>> A LOT OF MY CONSERVATIVE
FRIENDS WOULD LOVE TO SEE ME